dégoûté par ce que j'ai entendu parce
que je n'ai pas j'ai pas suivi
l'ensemble du discours et je le regrette
mais parce que je n'ai entendu je crois
que le nouveau monde pour le coup ne
réinvente pas grand chose parce que là
on a une liste de dispositions qui ne
sont pas chiffrés qui sont sans doute
plein de bons sentiments et mon
sentiment quand même mon impression
c'est que le président macro ne doit pas
bien connaître aujourd'hui le monde de
la pauvreté de la précarité le monde du
handicap 0 justement sur ces soins
dentaires ou optiques d'audioprothèse
qui seront remboursés à 100% ça ce n'est
pas une mesure en faveur des plus
démunis
absolument c'est une c'est une très
bonne mesure que l'on a déjà défendu qui
la suit d'ailleurs d'un certain nombre
de dispositions qui avaient déjà été
prises et là moi je souscris pleinement
le problème c'est après c'est dans la
méthode puisque on est là sur des
systèmes mutuelle
et qui permettent effectivement avec les
complémentaires de santé et c'est
d'arriver à aller plus en charge 0 et ça
permet bien évidemment pour ce qui
concerne les prothèses audio pour les
lunettes pour les dents d'avoir une
prise en charge complète et moi je
souscris complètement à cela puisque
c'est une demande qu'une région depuis
longtemps après il faut bien évidemment
que là aussi il est l'adhésion des
professionnels
et puis il faut aussi que la conséquence
de choix pas immédiatement un impact sur
une augmentation de l'adhésion fade et
des mutuelles ou les complémentaires de
chanter sur ce discours on le désire
dont la principale mesure est finalement
ce reste à charge 0 ce remboursement à
100% pour ses soins dentaires opting
d'audioprothèse avec des annonces aussi
pour les personnes qui renoncent
traditionnellement aux soins notamment
envers les plus jeunes il y aura les
dépistage accru chez les dentistes pour
les jeunes âgés de 3 ans à 24 ans j'ai
pas entendu l'ensemble du disque on non
plus mais j'ai cru voilà j'ai un peu
scinder les choses effectivement il ya
eu beaucoup d'annoncés autour du de la
prise en charge du reste à charge 0
pardon est dû à la prise en charge à 100
% notamment d'un panier de soins parce
qu'un important de repositionner les
choses moi j'aurais tendance à dire
qu'il ya de bonnes annonces qui vont
dans le bon sens mais il ya beaucoup
d'annoncés très générales qui ne sont
derrière pas décliner d'actes très
concret on parle traîne de très
nombreuses fois le président a annoncé
prévention par contre je ne vois pas
derrière de révolution ou en tout cas de
changement de paradigme en termes de
prévention
j'étais très attaché à attendre de ce
discours une nouvelle manière de voir la
santé et les soins
et si on repart cepalc à sa vie en
danger j'ai pas le sentiment qu'on fasse
cette révolution prévention au profit ou
en tout cas aux dépens de la révolution
du soin nous sommes toujours sur des
budget annuel calculé financièrement
bien évidemment il ya des budgets
respecter mais on ne prend pas en charge
on ne prend pas en compte en fait les 10
15 ans qui s'annonce devant nous pour
transformer complètement puisqu'il de
transformation complète donc moi
j'aurais tendance à dire ok pour la
transformation allons-y allons plus loin
dans la prévention et par périodes
allant vous
on prend un petit exemple sur les
certains pays du nord en suède par
exemple sur les dents aujourd'hui dans
certaines universités en suède il ne
soigne plus on apprend plus à soigner
certains soins que l'on fait ce que l'on
fait si chez les enfants tout simplement
parce que la prévention a pris pas sur
le soin et ses résultats justement avec
ces mesures justement de prévention pour
éviter bien d'arriver à des prothèses
dentaires
c'est une consultation c'est une
consultation alors on ya la prévention
et à la surveillance mais on n'est pas
sur des actions fortes en termes de
prévention alors oui une consultation à
trois ans et je sais pas j'ai pas tenu
jusqu'à 24 ans jusqu'à 24e à une
deuxième fin tous les ya un rythme qui a
été là ça va encore mais où on a encore
pas annoncé les rythmes c'est parce
qu'ils adhèrent cette consultation est
ce que ces dépistages une carie mais
dépistage d'une carie et prévention
c'est pas du tout la même chose que la
prévention va bien bien évidemment plus
loin donc moi je suis un petit peu déçu
sur ce sujet là concernant la le reste à
charge 0 alors je vais séparer mois les
prothèses auditives et les lunettes
encore une fois la prévention dentaire
qui pour moi est un acte médical voire
chirurgicale lorsque l'on parle de
prothèses on pourrait parler de
prothèses de hanche voilà et faisons
attention alors c'est une très bonne
chose dans le sens où effectivement les
personnes qui n'accèdent pas à ces soins
pour des raisons uniquement financières
pour aujourd'hui y accéder mais toutes
les personnes qui n'accèdent pas aux
soins ne sont pas partis pas toujours
pour des raisons financières
et là aussi on a un système d'éducation
et j'ai pas beaucoup entendu parler de
ce volet là et la deuxième chose c'est
de se dire il y à des soins qui vont
être à 100% mais c'est des soins
contrôler et gérer avec des prothèses
qu'on va plafonner quel type de prothèse
on va avoir derrière il y aura pas d
accord doit être conclu avec les
différents oui mais l'on laisse aussi à
regagner libron disons ceux qui veulent
la prothèse dernier crif où est la place
de l'innovation ça veut dire que les
plus démunis n'auront pas non plus accès
à une innovation c'est pas le
remboursement dont on avait enfin en
tout cas dont j'avais espéré à vendre de
continuer dans le détail peut-être du
cliché sur justement l'aspect le
chapitre santé en a entendu le seul de
l'état justement décliner son discours
avec trois chapitres santé âge exclusion
on annonçait bien sa vision
en matière de santé basé sur la
prévention est-ce que vous avez été
convaincu moi je souscris totalement à
cette idée de prévention j'ai pas une
innovation se dire que ça se fait depuis
longtemps la prévention elle se fait
aussi avec les professionnels de santé
et je pense que la question qui est
posée en fait derrière toutes les
annonces qui sont faites aujourd'hui
c'est la question d'abord de des
financements parce que si c'est un
discours qui couvrent des volonté de
réduire les dépenses et de faire des
économies
bah on en comprend tout le sens il est
généreux mais il n'est pas financé
donc à mon avis vis-à-vis des
professionnels si on veut faire de la
prévention il faudrait aussi financer la
prévention ce qui sera à mon avis à
terme source
effectivement d'une économie puisque les
gens n'auront plus besoin d'avoir
recours aux actes médicaux
donc ça ça c'est un aspect qui est très
très important sur la question de la de
la prise en charge 0 la question qui se
pose est que dieu accueille tout à
l'heure c'est la question de la qualité
des soins est ce que quand on est entré
en charge 0 on a une qualité de soin a
minima on a des outils des équipements à
minima ou est ce que tout le monde
reçoit même qualité de service sans
cesse des aspects qu'il faudra éclairer
bien évidemment sans les crises et en a